they don't do extended cuts really but I
feel like any game even if they had an
extended cut people tuned for that
yeah let's good Schneider cuts good I'm
glad recovering yeah free kills everyone
grow up guys sick all these people
coming in being like my heroes don't
grow up living in a dream world you
think Bruce Wayne did moral things ever
and held himself up to a moral
standpoint of any kind no we'll take
those sarcastic comments however you
would hello there reject nation
I'm Greg Alba I'm John Humphrey we are
going to talk about some Avengers and
game news something that was released on
the weekend some that came out today
first bit of news I want to talk about
some posters have been revealed now
we're not the kind of people who usually
talk about posters they actually just
have this discussion the other day
what's the point in talking about
posters if there's really a trailer
that's out you know that's like people
were luke talking about the far from
home posters like why what's there to
talk about they're still they usually
don't say that it's exciting if there is
not a trailer yet but the marketing for
end game especially after the way the
marketing for infinity war went down and
then having the infinity war movie come
out and knowing like oh [ __ ] they miss
Lee doesn't they tweak footage and stuff
and now they have some posters that have
come out there's a couple of cool new
revelations that you have here for sure
they've confirmed that Sheree is dead
they got two different kinds of posters
the black and why's that say avenge the
fallen on their with it's cool Avenger
symbol and they're the Fallen but not on
the avenge which is kind of interesting
but this is avenge the fallen and the
black and white ones are the ones who
have definitely got it dusted Sheree as
we all saw in the end game trailer
numero uno that they had Sheree on
screen
I'm so under the impression that it
might be a mislead we don't know for
sure that she got dusted I'm kind of
wondering if in the marketing they're
just doing that to have us think that
she got they could have put anyone's
face on this Fareed and they could put
any fun space in black and white on this
poster yeah and then I'm gonna use that
gray area of like well we
know what happened yeah I know maybe
she's in peril of a different sort right
it's like we don't know for sure who got
dusted or who's just missing or who went
on the run you know so we don't know
about that but then there's some other
confirmations that have happened here
for sure Pepper Potts is alive based off
this because you know you always have
Tony talking to the helmet and sending
messages in those endgame trailers but
you're like this he know for sure she's
still alive and I know that we had those
green-screen leaked photos of pepper and
Susie Legos and warm languages alive
these leaked photos are actual plants
too you know makes me wonder that as
well especially with how clever their
roses have been with the marketing those
leaked photos are intentionally leaked
photos to mislead us as well honestly I
think that would be one of the smartest
things they can do because those always
come out with this guise of like oh
there's stuff they didn't want us to see
so that must be authentic and if they
can I mean they can easily manufacture
something like that exactly
and then we also have a big one right
here who hasn't been teased in any of
the marketing at least as far as I know
Valkyrie men in black internationals
Valkyrie is here yes that's really
excited because a big talk of where was
she and infinity war where we didn't see
any of Valkyrie for some reason I'm I
didn't even bother to go hundred Belger
he's gonna show up in this man you know
she was drunk for infinity Wars that's
the opening shot the hell is it it can
actually be pretty funny start off the
endgame was yeah yeah because there's
not gonna be any for the rest of the
very long run time so you have Valkyrie
who's confirmed to be alive and you have
Wang was also confirmed to be alive I
know a koi a was on is on the poster for
endgame which sort of a lot of
controversy every cast member was pretty
much listed on there except for Danai
gurira Wow which was a very upsetting
but I believe they fixed it afterwards
you know putting out some social media
thing if she should have been up there
the whole time
we're we're good people yeah mistakes
they're easy to fix that's one of
yeah at least they did fix at least she
gets part of this own standalone poster
right here yeah and you know happy
Hogan's confirm to be alive as well we
had the far from home trailer which was
happy Hogan and spider-man in there all
right the part of these posters that
most excites me is the fact that
Valkyrie is confirmed to be alive
because it schools wrong is he had time
and infinity war now this is gonna be
had a long spin-off movie after this
Doctor Strange won't come back yes
Valkyrie coming back Amin that's really
exciting because she was a standout in
Ragnarok everyone wanted her to appear
in infinity war and then you know they
come out a couple months later with men
and black international William Thorin
Valkyrie right there dude there's a
double feature for you watching Chris I
was worth Thompson these are some cool
posters you know you see some things to
theorize about even though that these
posters are very intentionally like
black and white means there's a dead
ones and the color ones mean they're
still alive or you know maybe not dead
whatever it okay I forget I thought
semantics technicalities soul world
whatever got decimated but the other
thing that was confirmed over the
weekend and I don't know how like legit
this confirmation is but basically
they're saying a vendors endgame runtime
is expected to be three hours and two
minutes which to me I go you could have
it be longer at this point in the game
sure make it longer it all I'll still be
there yeah yeah I mean this has been
news but to me it's not really that much
of news because I figured Avengers
infinity war was about two and a half
hours long that was an epic with a lot
to achieve as longer than two and a half
maybe I mean it was like a hundred and
fifty odd minutes or something yeah that
and so with all that there is to achieve
with this movie I'm not surprised at all
this would be three hours and I'm not
upset about it because I feel like you
have we've been building to this point
for 10 years sure I'll sit here for
three hours
Avengers movie why not you know I'm
I'm kind of wondering if the run time at
all would affect box office performance
I feel like there's probably speculation
out there people doing videos perhaps
going you know like the average
moviegoer I haven't seen anyone do
videos on this but I imagine that
there's a lot of like you know based off
of watching YouTube videos about the
average moviegoer probably might not
tune in for this because it's so freakin
long I don't know look at the success of
the Transformers series like half of
those movies border on being three hours
and yeah you've made a whole lot of
money with less justification for it so
III doubt that this movie would deter
people with its runtime honestly I mean
I feel like word of mouth will speak
higher volumes than anything else
I mean Return of the King was a very
very long movie and I was a juggernaut
of a hit it only got longer on home
video exactly
people still tuned it for that I feel
like for Avengers endgame I think even
for the average moviegoer I feel like
they'll be like all three hours long but
I feel like they're still gonna even if
you have a gripe about it I feel like
you're still gonna show up for the movie
yeah I mean with the level of investment
that there is in this series and the
fact that it is just such a cultural
event anyway I feel like even somebody
who isn't on board with a long movie
normally can make an exception here I
don't see it as being a major deterrent
now because everybody also knows
especially coming out of Infinity Ward
there's gonna be so many characters an
infinity war left us all going that
could've been a half hour longer maybe
yeah so uh yeah I'm just curious as to
how they're gonna use that extra
half-hour I actually heard that Avengers
endgame or whatever this Avengers 4 film
was originally maybe it was always
called endgame I heard that they were
actually gonna start that off with the
decimation I can see that in but you
know I feel like last time they made the
smart move now they're gonna start like
that that was gonna be reserved for this
movie yeah see I see I see so we don't
even see it in Nvidia I think this was
the smarter move though
yeah it's young everyone has a good
cliffhanger it's not good for your
marketing but good for the cliffhanger
and get people to come back yeah
I mean I've still been refreshing
because we have a list the Ramos II I
still been refreshing the AMC insight
every single day and checking my email
notifications I know the endgame tickets
have yet because we're gonna go to a
press screening but nothing beat
opening night crowd no yeah it's that so
I'm like IMAX we can get it yeah if
we're lucky enough to get it I'm a guy
only go to two IMAX screens out here and
we got plenty but there's only two legit
ones I'm not gonna go to any of the like
the half-ass I'm experienced for this
point you know but still I want to go
either way to some theater with an
opening night Kratz even there were
going to a press screening we're gonna
wait in line for like an hour and a half
I said I still want to go with opening a
garage yeah feel the energy feel the
embankment man people who aren't jaded
I'm excited for this
these posters are cool run time doesn't
bother me and let's bother you guys is
what I mean I can't imagine the run time
would bother you guys feel like this is
the one time where people are like just
give us more give us more give me more
but before we wrap this video up I do
want to give a page from the day shout
out to a man named Taylor Bentley who I
believe has been decimated oh this guy
found himself a girl I don't even know
if he's still whether or not last time
we talked was months ago about how he's
landed himself a hot girlfriend who has
complete control over and narcissistic
abuser Taylor's the victim of all this I
haven't heard from him he stays pledged
to our patreon page I miss you if you've
been decimated still find a way to send
me an email or something because I would
like to hear back from you man I miss
you become a whisper along a mournful
wind or something like that you know
something your tours here that will hear
you buddy or come back is like a force
ghost cuz you know this is all under the
Disney umbrella now unless your
girlfriend becomes a force ghost too and
then you'll have to kind of do whatever
due to his girlfriend's hot she could be
however means she wants you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and can't you
guess soon